avec un benoît muracciole président de
l'association action et lyon était
éthique républicaine
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france quel regard est ce
que vous portez sur la situation au
yémen aujourd'hui on assiste à une
accélération des combats entre cette
coalition donc dirigé par l'arabie
saoudite et les émirats arabes unis même
s'ils sont un peu plus en retrait
maintenant et les outils d'autre part
sans aucun respect du droit
international
c'est intéressant de dire que la russie
le souligner parce que cela fait déjà
six ans que ce droit international n'est
pas respectée et elle avait été très
silencieux jusqu'à maintenant les cinq
pays membres du conseil de sécurité sont
très silencieux sur la situation au
yémen
à l'exception dernièrement des états
unis qui ont déclaré qu'ils suspendaient
les exportations d'armes en direction de
des pays dirigés par la larrabee ses
idées de la coalition qui intervient
donc dans cette guerre mais la france et
la grande bretagne notamment continue
d'exporter des armes et donc de soutenir
les graves violations du droit
international crimes de guerre et
d'après notre rapport que vous pouvez
trouver sur azer tirer asso.org des
crimes contre l'humanité les rebelles
houthi ont réalisé pour la deuxième fois
une attaque majeure en arabie saoudite
hier le conflit armé et le conflit armé
ils mènent étaient en train de quitter
le pays alors il ya quelque chose qui se
tend parce que les partis sentent que la
communauté internationale quand même et
notamment la décision des états unis
mais aussi du gouvernement italien et du
gouvernement australien de suspendre les
ventes d'armes va les mettre dans une
situation nouvelle donc chaque partie
essaye d'accélérer l'avantagent sur le
terrain avantage tactique qui est
stratégique sur le terrain
malheureusement cet avantage stratégique
et tactique qui se fait au détriment
encore une fois que des populations
civiles
puisque aucune des deux parties ne
respecte ce droit international une des
solutions
ce qu'il était plusieurs fois dit ce que
nous avons
plusieurs fois dit si votre antenne
c'est qu'il est absolument nécessaire
que les états occidentaux notamment
cesse de nourrir cette guerre en
continuant leurs exportations d'armes
c'est pour ça que azer un saisi le
tribunal administratif que maintenant à
zaire et d'autres ong sont devant le
conseil d'état pour demander la
suspension de ses exportations d'armes
de la france car elle risque une
véritable complicité avec ses crimes de
guerre et crimes contre l'humanité
vous voyez-vous perspective une
possibilité d'entamer des pourparlers
entre les deux camps
voyez même aujourd'hui bon c'est
toujours je me répète mais il ya deux
conditions pour qu'un conflit s'arrête
c'est l'épuisement des combattants et ça
sur le terrain ne savons pas ce qu'il en
est parce que ce ne pouvons pas aller
sur place et le deuxième point c'est
bien sûr l'arrivée des armes et dont les
munitions or ce deuxième point qui
pourrait être facilement contrôlé par
les états membres du conseil de sécurité
notamment encore une fois la france et
la grande bretagne qui sont partis du
traité sur le commerce des armes et bien
dans ce traité sur le commerce des armes
l'article 6 dit que si les armes
pourrait servir à des crimes de guerre
des crimes contre l'humanité de génocide
etc
les états doivent cesser toute
exportation d'armes qui pourrait servir
s'ils ont connaissance de or les
rapports des nations unies des experts
des nations unies disent bien qu'il y à
des crimes de guerre donc les états sont
au courant il s'agit maintenant d'une
décision politique il ya une décision
politique au niveau du conseil de
sécurité
il ya une décision politique au niveau
de la population yéménite et des
autorités yéménites
parce que bien sûr si on ne peut pas
décider la place des gens mais ce qui
pourrait être fait dès maintenant
aujourd'hui comme l'a fait d'ailleurs le
l'administration bergen c'est d'arrêter
ses ventes d'armes
c'est le plus important c'est ça qui
permettra un espace de dialogue entre
les parties et qui permettra une
respiration et surtout qu enfin l'aide
humanitaire arrive aux populations
civiles
du yémen on compte d'après le rapport
des nations unies sur pour le
développement plus de deux cent mille
morts aujourd'hui dans cette guerre dans
ces pénitents à cannes à sucre au bic
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris tant de de
répondre à nos questions ce soir benoît
amour hatcher je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association acer actions
sécurité éthique républicaine
monsieur